foreign
uh so we got uh
um lots of solutions here and I guess
maybe I'll go around the table and ask
for people to say something
that they think is is interesting
perhaps about their solution or
noteworthy or something for discussion
and let me start on the other side
because I've been usually talking to the
people near here so what what about you
did you uh uh Kathy did you actually
complete a solution to this one um I was
working at the Neil and Karen
um and an antibiotic program which we
just which we generate we just um
possible possible values news that
printing technique we talked about in
the last class we're using the suffix
test so I think what we've done has been
more or less dispersed brilliant for the
last class
um along and so that's fairly
straightforward and then it's so it's
pruned a lot of them
um possibilities left from a few
conjectures which then improved by hand
uh well we didn't prove them all by hand
we go for example perks built a few more
than you might approve
one star free stuff full stop and I've
shared that one one star three star four
stars that's not sorry I have it wrong I
proved one one star
three star
six five seven that's just an example of
a negative proof okay do you have a
proof that that doesn't work that that
doesn't work oh okay well well with uh
with at least one one yeah it was at
least one yeah
one plus or one yeah yeah okay
um
so I'm working now because they're doing
long multiplication
uh and we found out that if you have
something for example one six five seven
um
which which is an internet family okay
it's interesting to notice that if you
multiply that by six which is the
repeating digit then you get
um
all right okay you get something with a
lot of zeros in the middle of it so
anything engine two it has a lot of
zeros in the middle okay
foreign
yeah it's interesting
that all the cases the names that
families that work you have that
property that you end up with the cross
products having a lot of zeros in the
middle if you think about that in terms
of long multiplication if you work out
if you do some normal patient it means
you're never adding n
um
in numbers okay oh
that's right it's okay if you run out
then into just one multiplication
means what this is a nice thing oh sorry
okay
one notification means you do
multiplication the highway right now you
multiply one six star seven by seven and
you write that down and
and then you add
1607.5x6 and so on nothing easy
so I see so the reason so the six is
interesting because it's the thing that
you've got your long multiplying by a
lot a lot yeah okay so now you have one
when you multiply by seven you get some
do something but when you multiply by
six you get one zero zero zero zero two
and then and then multiply by six to get
this again and again and again and again
that's what you're saying yeah so you
just got a whole bunch of zeros in there
yeah that's right which is why this is
working
we didn't we couldn't well we didn't
actually prove that that was
um necessary it seems to be a nice
product a nice property you'd like to
have because it's nice
seem to make things easier but we didn't
prove
but it's necessary yeah uh I I I would
be surprised if it could be it says it
seems that the probability is very small
but there's always a chance that it
might that some some condition like this
might uh might occur
um I thought of um of generalizing the
problem slightly so that we would ask
for all pairs of numbers so that if you
write x and x squared
uh below each other and you look at
these pairs of digits like you have a
zero here presumably in a one here maybe
and then you know some more zero and
finally you end up with something over
here like uh seven nine something like
that and and you want these instead of
requiring that that uh that XP
non-increasing uh you know
non-decreasing the x squared be not
increasing just require that these organ
pairs been on decreasing
the same kind of a suffix condition can
be used in order to generate these so so
uh you in other words it says that
whenever you have two two repeated
digits of x and the digits below it x
squared would have to be uh uh it would
have to be uh in in correct order but
otherwise
um no condition
no I mean I was going to put x squared
on top and I was going to consider this
to be my primary key in X to be the
secondary key uh that meant that x
squared then would they would be in
order it would be assorted but X
wouldn't have to be and I had a feeling
that probably I would pick up all of the
this all of the um
squares
that are sorted that way all the perfect
squares there'll be infinite families
more infinite families in this case it's
a weaker condition
um
uh but uh
there might be a few cases that I missed
and as I said the other day that once
you get if you if you're trying to solve
x squares
um
x squared uh equals dot dot dot and then
you have some some uh
thing at the end here
um so
um five five five
eight I don't know what to put here 41.
um any if it turns out that if you can
that uh
this will have a solution for X as long
as you can get it started
uh if you can get it going far enough
then then I can put any arbitrary
numbers here you know this
representation of Pi or something like
that and I can keep on finding more and
more digits of X so that x squared would
be would end with with a given number of
digits and so we you get in you get
every possible sorted pattern of digits
in x squared uh is is a possible Square
uh as far as that as a live possibility
that can't be true now
um unless you have some kind of a
technique for for ruling out other cases
so so by putting it in electric graphic
order by dictionary order I mean let's
put X on the bottom instead
um I mean these pairs are sorted 1-0
less than or equal one zero you know and
so on less than or equal so whenever I
have two into equal and x squared I
require X to be different
um the same kinds of methods that that
have been used for for this problem
could actually generate other families
like this but uh uh
with a little
uh but uh how would you know that you
that you found all the squares that are
increasing
um that sort of requires that after
you've got to a long
supposedly I I get a long ways and I and
I so I say that this if I have a certain
pattern here let's make it an increasing
pattern just for the record so suppose I
have three three
you know I want to say now is this going
to work if I stop at this point well
then I got X figured out to this many
digits and I and uh the the uh the odds
that f i Square X and I look at the
digits that come on here that they're
actually gonna gonna continue to be
decreasing uh it's very small so I got
very unlikely that it will finish but um
I I don't know of any Theory that's
going to help cut it off
for the general case
um
that reminds me of something I did want
to mention that do you know do you
realize that if there's a solution
to this in terms of X that there are
more than one there are several
Solutions because it turns out that uh
that uh welcoming does anybody have any
idea how many so if there's a solution
at all to this to this uh uh to this
equate which means x squared mods
suppose that there's a there's an X that
solve this can you tell me how many
other X's there are mod 10 to the 9th
that was that was solid
what the
infinite number of exes
just to remain so I'm only looking at
numbers from zero to uh uh to uh uh you
know nine nines
um certainly minus X will also do it you
know 10 to 9 minus X will be another
solution
um but there's always eight
or zero
provided that um
now that this number here is not a
divisible by high powers of uh oh two
and five
like zero x squared counter to zero that
has only one solution and the reason is
well you know somebody should be able to
figure out why there's eight Solutions
you see I I told you if you have one
solution X there's always another one
you can get by by taking the negative
but there's another sort of obvious
Solution that's also going to work
give the same square
I mean it's only obvious if you've been
playing with this first problem what I
thought it would be obvious maybe it's
not obvious because I'm I'm uh
saying it to
I'm making you nervous mic X Plus yeah
yeah X plus five and eight zeros
squared will will give you the same
the uh the same result too
and so minus X plus five plus almost so
that's four of them now there's another
the other ones I don't expect that to be
three but it turns out that there is
there there's a number y squared the mod
that's that Y is definitely not one and
my y squared mod 10 to the ninth is
equal to one
um
and uh uh there's uh of course one and
minus one and
five all zeros in the one and four all
all nines uh satisfied but there's
another sort of a fundamental solution
to this one and the Andro and the reason
is that it turns out that y
Amad
five to the ninth is equal to one and Y
mods
two to the ninth is is equal to minus
one
you know um equal to the ninth minus one
and so when you square it
it's not it's uh one mod both two five
to nine and two to the ninth and
therefore my ten to the ninth because
they're they're relatively prime so so
this not this um uh this this funny
number why I I had it written down once
it you can just compute it to any number
of places uh change nine to to Infinity
uh you know
or work with what they call 10 addict
numbers
which is uh to say that we that we can
that we take numbers that are in that
have an infinite expansion to the left
of the decimal point and it just means
that we uh that um uh we uh uh uh
approximate them by taking up their
remainders modulo powers of ten and uh
so so it's uh so there's some so
um you can consider that the the set of
of numbers that that go on and on to the
left
um and and we just Define them by uh uh
you know you can multiply such numbers
and and um
uh you can even take square roots of
of such numbers and uh if we can get
started and there's there's a square
root of one that's that's neither one
nor minus one
and so x y
and uh and minus x y
and X Y plus 5000 and minus X Y plus
five thousand now the other four roots
so there's eight Roots all together if
there's a rooted on
um
now if
this this number y seems to have seems
to have a pretty random decimal
expansion if it had if it's decimal
expansion had some interesting
properties then we could probably get
more squares some more solutions to this
problem
but the the um the generalized the
general uh
question then of all
find all
X so let's set x squared is sorted
um I see now no uh way to to to uh
resolve that problem
and someday if you think of it let me
know
I got off on the tangent here
uh so
um we we uh so so uh Kathy observes that
when you do long multiplication
um and if you so like you you can notice
this if you're programming this to to do
the you have an array of digits in you
and you multiply everything out uh and
in order to get the product and program
the the high Precision arithmetic just
the way we learned to to do it in school
then uh then zeros are seem to be
occurring on the way here and that's
that's uh it seemed that's
related to uh what seems to me that the
reason we're getting these infinite
solutions is just that 10 minus 1
happens to be a perfect square or
maybe it's more General Maybe not maybe
base 19 is also going to have
Solutions
because 18 is divisible by a perfect
square I don't know but I'm um somehow
in our groups we the fact that we had a
uh that that nine was a perfect square
and 10 was just one more than the
perfect square was was leading to this
thing maybe in your in your pumping
Lemma did it suggests that you might get
a similar phenomenon
well
um just just running the the program
that I had for base's other 110 for
turning on poles strings of
base five you can twos repeat all over
the place and well base five see five
minus one is the perfect square that's
almost nine there's nine now that's the
one repeated I think it's just anything
anything that's a multiple of a
if it has a square Factor then you know
okay so so the base the fact that the
base minus one has a square Factor
is is leading to that and I would
support them this idea that the uh when
when we carry out the lung modification
that uh we might we might be able to get
a string of
however
repeated digits if not zeros but you
know okay so so in base nine you were
getting more okay well I'll get to I'll
get to these other
um later so let me see uh then then uh
Andy you worked with who
um well I was working with Rich John Amy
and then Marianne out there kind of
combination of groups and I guess our
strategy is very similar to Kathy's
group
um we just use that pruning technique of
look into lowering digits and we had the
program come up with conjectures that
digits could be repeated or not and to
prove those well I guess our philosophy
was to minimize the effort the human
effort required by
um guys putting up the work between
machines and people so rather than
trying to write a that's why you have
four people in the group
anyway so we basically just proved
patterns by sticking an arbitrary string
into its X in front of uh whatever
pattern we wanted and then writing
little programs to verify that to to
prune up all possibilities of exponent
looking to starting digits
okay
um
still any yeah okay I just did the sort
of the same thing just tried to prune
off possibilities and um you and our
youth work together now no that's just
working around and
um
so and try to and then this one switches
to the program couldn't couldn't prune
off I still haven't I can approve in my
hand and I still haven't done that
completely
right so um uh
I want to get back to the subject of uh
of a combined machine and hand work uh
later it's a good topic to to talk some
more about too Hari
our approaching simulator except that
we try to do the induction by uh we try
to write a program to do the induction
oh okay you and thanks
what we had was
we had some programs to to arithmetic on
the strings on the pattern strings
so that we could add pattern strings
or
we could multiply them by a number
not by another string but by a number
and we could
given the square of one smaller string
generate the
square of the string with something okay
so you have a you have an algebra where
you can say that this number times this
pattern is equal to this pattern yes and
then we generated the conjectures by I
mean we got this Quest generated the
conjectures that in the conjectures
about the squares we said okay this is
fine
and then again with the pruning
and I mean the conjunctivity it would
something the result of a conjecture
would either be yes no or maybe
yes or no yes or no that is for those
which did not have two lenses okay so
also so you had a complete theory for
that case essentially yeah for for the
case with one three unset
uh for two strings let me ask one more
question on your patterns did you need
to have a condition on the pattern that
there were at least
that n was greater than zero or
something like I mean did you have any
conditions that you had to have it yeah
well yeah the number of repeated digits
you have to have any lower bounds on
those yeah okay just assume that the
number was large enough okay
question
um
kind of with the symbolic multiplication
I mean we tried to come up with an
algebra to multiply
a pattern by a pattern to get a pattern
Etc
um
but and we were able to multiply a
pattern by a number as you said but
didn't you come up didn't you find a
place where you needed in squaring the
term to multiply a pattern by a pattern
so that in some sense you got
something that was variable in two
Dimensions like the term I'm going to
multiplying squaring one six to the N
seven
you can do 7 times 6 to the N quite
readily but six to the N times 6 to the
N you get kind of a square what we did
was we took this square of one lesser I
mean if you are taking if I want to find
out the square of 6 is 10 plus 1 7 I
assume this Square for six raised to N7
actually if you are I took as my
inductive hypo you have an induction
yeah
the solution for Success ten seven use
that to get six plus ten plus one seven
so so that's uh that's a another kind
that in obviously so the induction is
programmed and the induction only needs
in order to verify
that you get to the next step in the
thing it only needs a number by a plan
right now you said you were working with
Karen in the long time with pen okay
I'm sorry
because I heard everybody was claiming
to have worked with Cameron
um okay so so uh that was uh like we
were talking about
um on Tuesday so on this having uh
having a uh an algebra with q's and I's
you know the fact that you can multiply
qm times qn for example give give some
hope of having an algebra for certain
classes of patterns
uh times patterns but that's uh uh
if you combine it you know this is
interesting with the with induction he
didn't need that much power
but it would work for a string for
double strings I mean strings are two
variable thing uh I think it could be
made to work but uh
we had made certain assumptions
initially that the square of a pattern
with two strings would also would
contain only sums of I mean if it had
one string of length M and another of
length n yeah in the Square we would
only have strings of length M plus n
when it turned out there were some
strings of the N minus n yeah and uh
programs are designed to have yeah
depended on in greater than n or n less
than and that's that's uh uh this this
is a similar kind of uh thing when it
has happened in when people write
programs that are trying to
automatically prove correctness of of
other of other loops and they could
usually do a an induction they can they
can formulate a loop assertion or an
induction hypothesis when there's one
Loop but when they when when there are
two Loops coming in uh uh then then they
almost always break down no but that I I
have a feeling that it could be done I
mean it's just that we have not written
this program yeah right it could be done
uh some program could could do it yeah
but that's yeah if it raises the next
and
the complexity probably is is uh squared
at least
in that yeah
okay Dimitri yeah I was working with
John Woodfield and our approach was
basically the same we did the suffix
test for uh
safeties of length at most ten and so we
found out we guessed the correct
patterns we found out that the
patterns that
could not be discarded it's actually
that would not be discarded
according to five other patterns
we did with the repeating threes or
sixes we did some improved by hand for
the squares of those patterns we found
that is we found the bottom of the
square and express it in a way that the
TA can guess and you can be sure it's
correct oh no carries okay and then we
fade in for at least for those who had
just one ripping string going to bring
digit we found in the computer the
pattern for the number in the bottom for
the square
those were one linked with an acceptable
number and for the others that had two
they've been straight two repeating
digits
waited somewhere by hand and the most
interesting was and there is a need for
the second time in glamor the global
pumping yeah and all three and a five in
the north sixes and a seven where you
fail if the number of Threes greater
than the number of sixes
yeah five
n
is n plus one then it fails we throw the
suffix step right uh
okay so this this must have come up and
in other people's programs if they if
the program were correct right
so now is it this one keeps going and
going and going
uh until end steps minute and then it
cuts off wow
okay
so when you have a complete rigorous
proof that deal yes for base then for
base ten okay base 16 we checked we saw
the pattern from a 16 at base 16. the
base 17 17 oh okay there will be too
many patterns to prove in icing our Pros
um
but did you try any other basis besides
10 and 17. so raise five base six
production base six and Basics
there was no pattern there's no pattern
we just had you just uh just two or
three numbers okay well
that's uh six minus one is Prime and
sorry we've got to have a square in
there if we're going to get something
okay very interesting so let me see if I
covered
I just have a question about that double
thumping them apart again yeah um how
about if you uh if you consider like to
prove that one consider two three right
if you're dealing with more threes and
sixes then consider it's a half the off
the offset I guess Roger called it the
the the right hand offset to be two
three to the N7 then when M gets large
enough you can use the pumping on the
and if there are more sixes then you
consider to be a left offset of power
from any three to the M5 okay so you're
so you're you're uh I mean erase this
I'm saying that um
uh we had dilemma we had the ethereum
out on Tuesday and so we you might
consider this if m is large it's in the
script you have two cases of
demonstrated and then okay so suppose m
is greater than n
then then we consider this to be 3 to
the M plus
and something plus b yeah
um squared where
where B is
all these numbers to the right
and um and provided that we get M plus n
large enough
with respect to B
then then the uh that that theorem tells
us that that this will
work for an all-sufficiently large gem
or not represents that's it that's the
point so if m is large we you would get
a failure from the other one if we had a
sharp estimate for for how large
how large this has to be and perhaps it
doesn't have to be much larger
I mean maybe m equals n Plus One will be
large enough
yeah good that's a good point and and
you're saying when m is less than or
equal n then you would consider this to
be six to the
yeah you make six to the N six six n
plus one and then you have your
and then you had yours
there was another term in here then it's
uh 10 to the N times
um
whether we call it B or C I forget C is
I don't remember how we did this okay so
so then C is that would represent a
small number of it I mean and as long as
that
and and uh the the the uh point is that
the the
um the pumping dilemma that we had on
Tuesday
um said that for us if we take this
repeating part
um and let it get large enough then all
those numbers are sorted or all those
numbers are not sorted and large enough
depended on the on the uh the size of
the other of the other consonants in
here in this case this depended on V in
this case it dependent on C
and if we get if we look very uh closely
at exactly what it means to be large
enough by chasing down our proof and
seeing how how much it might be sharp
enough to rule out this case because C
would be
something that's um the number of digits
in C
and including the three and the five
would be
small enough with respect to uh n here
and similarly the number of digits here
would be small enough with respect to
this
M plus n
okay
now let's see then left is a mic and
Roger
um yeah we finish for the stuff that
Roger well Roger uh refined his pumping
on a bit um wrote a program to test
numbers using it
Oh I thought you I'm gonna say you wrote
a program to refine pumping level
it should be pretty neat okay
yeah private program which sounds a lot
like a recent times oh yeah and
um basically have the same problems with
it it only worked if you had one
repeating string in it
and so I've tried writing a program
which handles more than one repeating
string
and it looks like your hypothesis of the
complexity gets squared is true
um
that was on your lower that was only a
conjectured lower but I don't say upper
bound
like I said it doesn't work yet but you
but you do have something that that
proves induction you know is it
formulates induction hypothesis and and
sometimes says yes or no uh the the
first program the first book yeah um
and essentially just it starts out the
way
the um the simple ones to building a
number up from the right hand side as
soon as it starts seeing repetitions it
then tries to form an induction if all
system proven
the repetition just uh doesn't have to
occur twice or just that before this
what I picked four okay
um
so I was wondering about whether or not
this should be whether or not this
number of repetitions should be uh
uh considered as part of a branching in
other words you you either you you have
a you have a a case of branching and you
can say well either
n is greater than two or n is equal to
two
and if n is equal to two you have a you
don't have a case that you can try
without considering that a pattern has
occurred but if n is greater than two
then you can use a pattern that relies
for its proof on the fact that n is
greater than two I'm not sure if this is
a an important idea or a valuable ID or
not but that that is instead of choosing
an arbitrary number
consider that you that that's just one
other thing in your branching in your
tree that is you either go through a
pattern or you or you don't and
something like that and and uh
you um uh you have to catch that you
don't get infinite truth
infinite uh yeah
yeah
okay so it's that's uh uh uh it's a
program that's
that you think might work soon huh yeah
start okay
Roger as well got the double pumping
llama
um
um you have to get too specific about it
but
I'll just if you if you put it in terms
of Threes And sixes okay um
you've got say three to the m
6 to the N
um
yeah you got something out of the
beginning something added in the middle
something
plus this plus b is that what well B and
then this is an also another thing you
can you can add something times 10 to
the N oh middle okay
um
the idea is that if
M and N are sufficiently big and
sufficiently big depends on b d and c
um you can expand simultaneously
you can get the same sequence of digits
in the Square
then
then all of these are are good or all of
them are bad yeah for Central at all and
and this
uh so the proof is somehow gets around
the problem as to whether m is greater
than n well it's just it assumes that
you just you just pick
and the MS
um n minus n is fixed
M minus m
it is you just leave that fixed and
you can
only when you look at the square you've
just got
um our you you consider you consider
your your proof says let
k equal n minus n well actually the
proof and N plus Nu in place of M and
then I just worked on N oh oh oh so this
is but it's I mean and then you can do
another one with with end plot with
well
you do want you do one proof with with n
plus Nu in place of M up there yeah and
then you do another proof with say M
plus mu in place of n where mu and Nu
are non-negative or yeah mu and Nu are
just non-negative and fixed okay
and okay and then uh combining those two
combining those two reminding gives you
golden things that maybe you could get
it as a chrome area
single oh no no you can't not quite good
not quite sharp enough
um I think the problem is trying to use
the single one twice is that you
to apply the single one you have you
would have to have an infant number of
Base cases proven when you have to
improve our you have to have arbitrarily
large base cases to start pumping
and you need to double one to get those
um
I mean in the example with threes and
sixes and sevens
to pump the threes you need
more threes and sixes
and so you have to prove it for
you have to prove at least one case for
each possible value of six with Mark
threes without
it okay well some
discussions like that means we have a
formal proof of impossibility of
deriving it a corollary you know it's a
it's a matter of us but it's
did this proof cover more than the case
for which
n minus n is fixed and they're increased
and kind of boxed up
um no so that's that's all it covers
that's all it covers
um to actually to actually close out all
the possibilities on base 10 you've got
to um
you've got to combine the single Lemma
with the double Emma very carefully they
combine that one with the two over there
and that should this one will generate
all the base cases for that well what
you have to do yeah is you have to start
out with a large enough number of sixes
so that
um
up until a certain number of freeze
you'll be able to keep the obviously
able to pump the sixes
then once you get to the point where the
um the threes get too large to pump the
sixes then the double pumping level has
to be able to take over pump them both
out okay
um in the meantime you keep adding you
can and then then you can keep adding
threes on the end until you get until
you're able to pump the threes and then
that
um it sounds like this ought to be uh
you know it's it's going to be very
difficult to go through uh all the all
the detail but the main main idea but
have I stated the correctly here yeah
that's that's a very useful function
capital n and BC indeed such that all of
these are equivalent to each other as
far all sorted are all non-sorted
connection now and and that's and that's
proved using using uh the uh some
combination of techniques from this it's
the same technique as the single
elements so there's this
well he's he's claiming that that he's
proved this in general though that there
exists of function Capital you prove it
for an arbitrary fixed difference
between m and n
so you have an infinite number of
equivalents classes
you see that's the thing is you don't
um yeah they have they have to grow and
lockstep
um
so so this so I mean showing showing
just one
that I mean that's quite well
um that's why you have to um you should
not write down a sequence of numbers
okay sequence of numbers just write down
like a six to the
you can put down six to six okay okay
actually okay put down
well don't even do a lot of writing that
way but okay well done whatever you want
to write it I I should I just wanted to
um try to I mean first of all the
questions we have two uh Anil is saying
you've only proved this a statement that
seems weaker you've proved you've proved
uh two statements of the form
you know went in
you know if if
M minus n equals K positive negative or
zero
there exists an N Sub k for which M
greater than N Sub K or b c d
has this property
now on the other theorem is there exists
an n
such that for all m n greater than or
equal to
capital n
we have the uh they're all they're all
sort of they're all unsorted
this is saying for all k
there exists an N Sub K you know those
are not obviously equivalent yeah
statements what you are actually it's
one of these things that's a lot easier
to see graphically
you got a bunch of sixes so let's assume
that just for now that we have enough
okay we just
um fill this volume
and
um
okay so we consider three three three
three three three
okay at some point you'll get out far
enough
74. 3s that the
um
see what the
I always the same number of six is here
and then you've got
three out this much
and the idea is in order to use the
double Lema you need a minimum number of
sixes
and freeze okay so if you've got some in
we have to at least this at least that
many threes and at least that many sixes
so say that
that point is reached here okay and
to use a single Lemma to extend sixes
you can't have any more than a certain
number of threes
and the problem is you've got to search
out far enough
so that there are enough sixes that
these points overlap that is
you have a set of Threes here that you
can either just push out this way or
double pump okay so like you're gonna
have four threes follow them followed by
any number of sixes well followed by
this number six
um
reminds me of the number of the beasts
let's see let me let me start let me
start you back again
you you first prove this and then you
show that that establishes this
there's two there's two uh uh possible
theorems here we have we have a weak
form saying that for Australia there
exists and in some case
so that when whenever Eminem go in
lockstep then we have that
that Bond uh here's one that says that
there exists an N independent of you
know depending only on b c and d
oh well
um
okay now this is this is the one here
that's the one you approve yeah it's
um
that's not quite the forming
is this is definitely true that's
um
I think in my feet okay well let's let's
just say that the second one that it
doesn't look like the the triple pumping
on the movie is ready yet
to show here is the idea is you haven't
searched all of these and it searches
down far enough until it can just pump
the single free out okay and this will
cover all of the different patterns of
digits that can appear with with it with
with six sixes with any Arbiter any
arbitrarily large number of sixes in
arbitrarily large numbers of Threes
because then what happens is that given
some
that number
that would be large enough that you can
you can Pump It Down
and you'll either hit a point where k
um gets to gets to this number of sixes
and you'll still have a lot of freeze in
which case it'll fall in this area
so it'll be something you've covered so
so you are deriving it by means of the
first the first you need both of them
okay
um all right so so in other words you
have this weaker for this this form and
you have the one we had on Tuesday
between the two of them you exhaust all
the cases of your squares that's what
you're seeing there's a program and it
only works for base 10.
when you did have some other results so
if you found that for example in base
nine you had
you had an example is it easy to quote
it is it well you have an answer
um
I think the one I printed out is space
five
um
base nine is the one that that I was
most because the nine minus one is not a
perfect square
okay we don't have if you did have it
that would be
I think
um so I think I've covered all the
groups then is that correct
let's see if we can't
use a few minutes to think of what if
anything we've learned about while
working on this problem other than the
fact that all the squares that are
sorted in you know x and x squared both
are sorted are are a certain
um a certain set
um what what do we find more more
generally well we learned some things
about
about numbers
uh about number Theory uh that might
have been new
um I learned things about
us you know rep units that I didn't know
about as far as minimum coins are
concerned things like that but I'm
trying to abstract away a little more
from that and I think one of the key
things has been that we we uh have to
it's the issue that Andy brought up
earlier about what about The Interchange
between uh programming and having a
computer do everything automatically and
doing something by by hand now
um
uh
it's uh it's possible to to of course to
set ourselves a goal that I can we'll
read write a computer program that would
solve all problems in the world or we
can find some cut off and say no our
program should should solve as much as
some reasonable amount and after that uh
after all we could yeah we're we're
there and we can we can be uh uh
available to help write the to help the
program sometimes it's easier for us to
write a proof than to write a program I
mean the program might even be wrong
because
uh uh I mean the less reliable in our
than our proof if it gets too
complicated
um so uh one of the one of the things
that seems to come up here is that we
that that we we try to find a a subset
of all of all mathematics uh some small
theory that we can actually that's
that's sufficient to do the kind of
problems that we're interested in this
seems to me like very much like the idea
of inductive closure when we're trying
to just prove something by induction in
a mathematics course where where you
have a problem that you want to prove by
induction but your induct but the
theorem that you that you uh that you
want to prove isn't strong enough to
prove Itself by induction so you need to
prove something more and then you can
prove then it's easier to prove more
because that will more will also carry
through in the induction steps
um so so you look for some some uh
something that's that so that all the
smaller cases of the general thing
you're trying to do is also included in
it and it's rather similar to trying to
search for
um what what you need for uh uh for a
class of things that you can handle in a
program like this for example we we
needed uh uh to to be able to deal with
multiplying a string of some pattern by
another by another digit
and uh
and so it's natural in the search for
for theories but uh that that says that
if we have a pattern we can uh if if our
computer is going to represent now not
just numbers but patterns of numbers
then uh what operations do we have to be
able to do on patterns in order to in
order to keep within a system that will
be enough to to carry out the whole
proof in order to in order to do it this
week you start out uh usually uh it's
like a closure process that you start
out with the smallest amount that you
have to do you need numbers you need
simple patterns and then you you see
well now see do I what else do I need
and yes and and you you come to the
conclusion that oh yes I need to
multiply a pattern by a number so you
put that in then uh uh Arif pointed out
that he was able to get a lot of mileage
out of just that because he could use
induction uh without having to multiply
pattern by pattern uh explicitly
um in the in the uh on Tuesday with the
identities I was writing down like Q
you know q m times q n equals r M plus n
minus RM minus r and that point of that
was
to try to to say that we could have a
computer that was able to deal with
um linear combinations of
of Q's in the X variables and linear
combinations of ours in the x squared
variables and then we could we could
imagine a program that that was able to
manipulate a formula like R sub n plus n
minus r sub n minus r sub n so this
program wouldn't have to manipulate all
formulas in the world but this this kind
of formula looked like we might we might
need it in our in our Theory uh several
you figured out how to do without that
um several of you figured out how to do
it by hand with uh with the computer
telling you what what the cases were to
uh to verify and just then presenting
you with a small small cell
um
so so the uh I think this has given us a
little bit of in in of uh insight into
uh interactive problem solving electric
lighting letting people and computer
work together
and uh I I raised this because problem
two is going to be a lot of that uh
com2 will be the cryptanalysis problem
it hasn't run that now let's see what
was the
answer about base nine there's one
followed by fours and five
and cool so so let's let's give an
example in base nine uh that I can just
write down okay four four four five four
four four five page nine squared
is equal to it's four twos
three sixes
okay
there is an example then where where
nine
um minus one is not a perfect square but
it still has
patterns like this in the presumably
this generalizes 10 to any number yeah
okay
and four four four
is one half isn't it this is a this is
just a little more than one half
base nine
uh when you got an odd base
um you can't represent I mean in in uh
it's something like
0.667 is is two-thirds you know 0.445 is
is one half
in base nine
so we're squaring it and getting one
fourth
um sort of in base nine
okay well uh any other comments on what
uh what uh what general ideas we might
have
the insights we might have gotten you
know from working on Prop one
so
um
the uh the the uh
it's not it's hard really to say why we
learned anything we had on on the
week and a half